FNB
[Music]
concept
Islam.
Okay.
She has two questions. Dr. Zakir, I've
allowed only one. The question is, what
is the concept of God in Islam? And how
is this concept of God different
compared to other religion? I request
the director that if there can be two
cameramen in the front Sachin can you
call the other person in the question
session there should be two in the front
one with following me on the camera
sitting and one on the coordinator. So
tell the DP to get one more cameraman
the second one to help you out as the
question poses that sister wanted to
know what is the concept of God in Islam
and how does it differ with other
religions.
This is a talk my son would be giving in
Jakarta. I think it's on the 20th of
July. Concept of God in major world
religions.
Regarding a question, what is the
concept of God in Islam? The best reply
any Muslim can give you regarding the
concept of God in Islam is quote to you
surah class chapter number 112 verse
number 1 to4 which says
say he's Allah one and only Allah Allah
the absut eternal
he begets not nor his begotten
there's nothing like him this is a
fourline definition of Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala given in the glorious Quran
Anyone who claims to be God, if that
person falls in this four line
definition, we Muslims have got no
objection in accepting that person as
God.
Number one is say he's Allah one and
only. Number two Allah
Allah Allah the absolute eternal
he beget not nor is he begotten
and there's nothing like him. If you do
comparative study of the other major
religions, most of the major religion in
the scripture actually they talk about
the same to
all the religions all the major religion
if you study the scripture they talk
about the same concept of one god. For
example, if you read in the old
testament in the Jewish scriptures, it's
mentioned in the book of Isaiah chapter
number 43 verse number verse number 11.
I even I am God and besides me there's
no savior. In the book of Isaiah chapter
number 45 verse number 5, I am God and
there's none like me. There's no God
besides me. And I can keep on quoting
it's mentioned in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number four when Jesus Christ when Moses
peace be upon asked that which is the
first of the commandment he said.
O Israel the Lord our God is one God. So
if you read the Jewish scriptures, even
Jewish scripture says there's one God.
If you read the Bible, if you read the
New Testament, even in the New
Testament,
when Jesus Christ peace be upon asked in
the Gospel of
Matthew, gospel of Mark chapter number
12 29, which is the first of the
commandment, he repeated verbatim what
was said by Moses peace be upon him and
what the brother was saying.
here. O Israel, the Lord our God is one
God.
So if you read the Hindu scriptures, if
you read the Hindu scriptures, it is
mentioned in Sataranishad, it's
mentioned Chandoganishad chapter number
six, section number two, verse number
one,
God is only one without a second. It's
mentioned
chapter number four verse number 19
of that god there is no image of that
god there is no pratima. So if you read
the Hindu scriptures and the Brahma
sutra of Hinduism is
there's only one God. Not at all. Not at
all. Not in the least bit. There is not
a second God. Not at all. Not at all.
Not in the least bit. So if you read the
Hindu scriptures, even they talk about
one God. If you read the Pari
scriptures, even they talk about one
God. So all the major religions if you
study they speak about one god but
unfortunately the followers they are
being misguided and many a times they
ask them to do something else beside the
main pillar
whether it be Hinduism whether it be
Christianity then the church tries to
misguide them and say God is three in
one trinity
the word trinity doesn't exist anywhere
in the Bible but the church says that so
many of the Christians unfortunately
believe in trinity though the word
trinity doesn't exist anywhere in the
Bible it's there in the Quran
in surah nisa 4 171
don't say trinity
this stop it's better for you it's
mentioned maid 5 verse number 73 that
they are doing those who say those who
say so tinity It is mentioned twice in
the Quran both the time we say don't
say. So when we do comparative study
when we are Muslims we should guide our
non-Muslim friend that go back to your
scriptures read your scriptures
understand it and believe in one God and
this is the corner faith of all the
religions believing in one God. Hope
that answers the question.